have you ever noticed that after hanging
out or working with certain people you
feel like you're ready to Take On The
World these are the people who uplift
your spirits and fill you with energy
you want to be around them on the other
hand you've also probably come across
people who leave you feeling drained and
exhausted after every interaction it's
as if they cast a shadow over your mood
and motivation scientists have long been
aware of what they call relational
energy the fact that our interactions
with others can have a profound effect
on our mood in a study in 2003
psychology professors Rob cross Wayne
Baker and Andrew Parker came up with the
concept of an energy app they worked
with consultants and managers in a few
giant firms to establish who worked with
whom and the impact that any given
person had on other people's energy
levels their discovery that there was a
remarkable amount of agreement about who
was an Energizer and who was a drainer
even at the level of large organizations
people can enhance our mood and make us
more productive but this isn't a given
it requires deep thought about how we
connect with each other in this chapter
we'll explore various ways we can
surround ourselves with people to feel
more energized and to do more of the
things that
matter